we have breaking news out of Puerto Rico
at this hour a strong earthquake struck
overnight causing a blackout across the
u.s. territory the magnitude 6.4
earthquake hit just south of the island
now comes one day after a four after a
five point eight magnitude quake damaged
homes and caused landslides there the
mayor of the city of ponse told a local
station at least one person was killed
David beg NOAA's joining us now he's
been monitoring this developing story
listen David there's no such thing as a
good time to have an earthquake but this
is the last thing they need there
they're still recovering what are you
hearing and they've been dealing with
this series of earthquakes for the last
week or so right now I was just looking
on the USGS website there was just a 4.4
magnitude 5.8 4.5 they they won't stop
in fact people on the island are telling
me that a lot of them are staying
outside over fears that their homes may
collapse with future earthquakes this is
the largest in a series of earthquakes
that have hit the island in recent days
we have video from inside of a Barcelona
two grocery store this morning that
shows people really scattering and
taking off when the quake hit other
pictures show homes and buildings that
crumbled some houses were ripped to
their foundations other cars were
crushed underneath homes that collapsed
we have a social media image posted by a
local journalist that shows patients
evacuated on stretchers outside of the
Damas hospital in ponse now look
earthquake concerns have been growing on
the island of Puerto Rico the island
sits on a fault a very active fault and
has had about 700 earthquakes since the
end of December
most of those go unnoticed and get this
after yesterday's 5.8 quake I reached
out to a seismologist with the USGS to
find out what the chances were that
there would be something stronger than a
5.8 he put the odds at 3% and it
happened this morning the odds did not
work out in their favor
we spoke to Puerto Rico's power
authority the CEO I spoke to him just a
short time ago on the phone he said that
there was actually another earthquake
happening as we were talking he said
there is minor damage to the two largest
power plants on the island Palo Seco and
Costa stalled there was an automatic
shutdown of the power grid when this
morning's major earthquake happened and
so it was a protective measure
that the power plant shut down they hope
to get it back in service by noon I'm
actually getting off the set here and
getting on a plane to go
alright 700 eggs in a very short amount
thank you very much thank you
you